il se passe quelque chose en moi quelque
chose s'éveille dans mon esprit je n'ai
aucun contrôle dessus
qu'est ce que tu as vu
une croisade se prépare
[Applaudissements]
tu rêves souvent de choses qui se
réalise qu'elle que tu les avais vus oui
l'épreuve est simple si tu retires ta
main de la boîte tu mourras est ce qu'il
ya dans la boîte la souffrance
[Applaudissements]
tu as hérité une trop grande puissance
tu as prouvé que ton esprit commandes et
ton corps
il faut apprendre à commander les autres
une chose qu'aucun d'eux des ancêtres
l'a appris
mon père ou verne toute une planète elle
lui échappe il en aura une plus riches
elle lui échappera elle aussi
mungo raquer c'est un piège mortel
tuez les
[Musique]
c'est une extermination en règle
il élimine les proches les uns après les
autres on va se battre comme des lions
un animal pris au piège dévorera sa
propre patte pour s'échapper
qu'est ce que tu vas faire
je te connais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
un jour
naîtra naître de légende
[Musique]
toute une civilisation en dépend
l'avenir je peux le voir
[Musique]
je ne dois pas avoir peur
as peur tu l'esprit monseigneur lorsque
la peur sera passée il ne restera que
moi